انضم إلي الآن أحد
الخبراء الرائدين في العالم في تجارب التحدي البشري ،
أندرو كاتشبول هو
المسؤول العلمي الرئيسي لشركة h vivo ،
الشركة التي
تساعد في قيادة التجارب في لندن ، إنه
لمن دواعي سروري استضافتك يا
سيدي وشكراً لنبدأ ببعض
الأسئلة السريعة بسرعة  جولة إن شئت
أه لأولئك المشاهدين الذين قد يكونون
جددًا على كل هذا أولاً
ما الفرق بين تجربة
المرحلة 3 السريرية والتجربة
البشرية ودراسات التحدي البشري حيث نقوم
بتلقيح المتطوعين
مباشرة بالفيروس
بحيث يختلف ذلك  مرحلة عادية مجانية
حيث يتم إعطاء اللقاح للأشخاص في المرحلة الثالثة من التجارب
ثم يُطلب منهم أن يعيشوا حياتهم
الطبيعية وبالتالي
يكون الحظ عشوائيًا تمامًا سواء
تعرضوا للفيروس أم
لا ، وسنفعل المزيد في ذلك
لحظة كم عدد الأشخاص الذين سيشاركون
في هذه التجربة ،
لذا فإن هذه التجربة الأولى تدور حول
تحديد أقل كمية من الفيروسات
المطلوبة
لإحداث عدوى ، لذلك نحن نبدأ
مستويات منخفضة
للغاية ثم إذا لم يصاب أحد بالعدوى ، فسنبدأ
بالمستوى التالي للأعلى وسنستمر حتى نحصل
على عدوى مثبتة ، لذلك من الصعب
تحديد عدد الأشخاص
المطلوبين لهذه التجربة بالضبط لأنها
ستعتمد على عدد الجرعات  نحن
نختبر ذلك في مكان ما بين ما يتعلق
بالتركيبة السكانية ، وقد
حصلنا على ما يرام من 50 إلى 90. حسنًا ، ماذا عن
التركيبة السكانية
هنا ، كل شيء يتعلق بتقليل المخاطر ،
وبالتالي فإن التركيبة السكانية مرتبطة
بالتأكد من أننا نستخدم المتطوعين الأقل
خطرًا لهذه الدراسة
لمرض شديد ، لذلك  سنعمل مع الأشخاص
الذين تتراوح أعمارهم بين 18 و 30 عامًا ، على سبيل المثال ،
كم من الوقت ستستغرق التجربة
حتى تستغرق التجربة نفسها ما
بين شهرين إلى أربعة أشهر اعتمادًا على
عدد جرعات الفيروس التي نحتاج إلى اختبارها
قبل أن نتمكن من إنشاء
العدوى
وما هي المخاطر الرئيسية ،
لذا فإن المخاطر الرئيسية لأي
تجربة سريرية هي
أن المرض يتقدم أكثر مما
نتوقع وهذا هو سبب
قيامنا بعدد من  الجهات الفاعلة لتقليل هذه
المخاطر أولاً ، الحصول على جرعة منخفضة للغاية
من الفيروس
ثم نستخدم فقط الموضوعات ذات
المخاطر الدنيا ، أي لا يوجد عامل خطر معروف
للمرض
وكذلك نستخدم أيضًا مضادات الفيروسات كإجراء
وقائي لتقليل مخاطر  المرض الشديد
لم يحصل بعد على الموافقة الأخلاقية
من المنظمين في المملكة المتحدة. لماذا
هي مجرد مرحلة من العملية نحن
على الإطلاق يجب مراجعة التجارب السريرية بشكل
مستقل من قبل لجنة أخلاقية
ثم بالإضافة إلى ذلك
تمت مراجعته من قبل  المنظمون نحن في
المرحلة التي حصلنا فيها الآن على هذا العقد
مع حكومة المملكة المتحدة ،
لقد صممنا الدراسة ، ونحن على
وشك تقديم
خططنا للدراسة إلى كل من
مجلس المراجعة الأخلاقية
والمنظم البريطاني  مهرا